من التنمر ما قتل هذا حال الطالبه رودينا
اسامه التي اثارت حزنا المصريين بعد
وفاتها اثراء ازمه نفسيه حاده تنمر من قبل
زميلاتها جعلها ضحيه لحاله نفسيه ادت
لاصابتها بهبوط بالدوره الدمويه ادى الى
وفاتها في جديد القضيه استدعت جهات
التحقيق والد الطالبه في الصف الاول
الثانوي وذلك لسماع اقباله في الشكوى
المقدمه منه لاداره
المدرسه يتهم فيها احدى الطالبات بالتنمر
على ابنته والد رودينا كشف انها تعرضت
للتنمر عده مرات على شكلها من قبل بعض
زميلاتها وان ابنته روت له هذه الوقائع
وحاول تهدئتها لكنها تاثرت بشكل دالخ
سالنا الناس في مصر هل تعرضتم للتنمر في
المدرسه متابع
عمري ما تعرضت الموقف تنمر اثناء المدرسه
ولا دلوقتي ولا بتنمر على حد ولا حد بيمر
علي اعجبتني يا قصيره
كنت لابس نظاره وكده
كان ابو كشافات بقى وبربع عيون والشغل ده
فاهم
احيانا لا عادي كنت بضحك وهاخدها باخده
بهزار يعني
انا في الابتدائيه اتعرضت للتنمر كتير بس
كانت تصرف يعني
اتجاهل الموضوع وانت تضايق شويه اتجاهل
الموضوع شويه خدها بهزار شويه كنت اشد
شويه بتدايق في نفسك بتشيل بس ما بتقولش
ايام بس هو صاحبي بيشيل من النفسيه قوي
يعني بالنسبه للطفل وكده انا عندي ابني
هو بيتنمر على صحابه في الكيان في المدرسه
وكده بس انا بقول له لا ما ينفعش لا عيب
لا حرام
[موسيقى]
على كل اللي افهم اكثر من القاهره ينضم
الينا رئيس قسم التعليم في بوابه الاهرام
احمد حافظ اهلا بك يا احمد نريد اولا ان
نفهم القصه كامله ما الذي حصل مع الطالبه
وما قصه التنمر الذي تعرضت له وانت للاسف
لوفاتها
صباح النور يا فندم صباح النور طبعا
رودينا احنا بنعزي اسرتها اتمنى لها
الرحمه رودينا تدرس في الصف الاول الثانوي
في احدى المدارس الخاصه في منطقه فيصل في
الجيزه رودينا من اربعه ايام كده رجعت
البيت منهاره جدا وقعدت مع اختها الكبيره
في الاوضه يعني بدات تتكلم معها فبتسالها
هل انا شكلي وحش هل انا وحشه للدرجه اللي
ما بتخليش حد يلعب معي ويتبراوا مني
فاختها بتسالها ليه قالت له اختها ان هي
اصحابها بيضايقوها جدا وحالتها النفسيه
سيئه جدا وقالوا لها انت مش من مستوانا
يعني لان هم بيقولوا ان هم في طبق اعلى
مني فهل انا مش من مستواهم فعلا وبدات
تبقي تحكي لها ان هم زمايلها كانوا
بيضايقوها جوه الفصل وكانوا بيرفضوا ان هي
تقعد على الديسك بتاعها وكانوا يكتبوا
اساميهم على الديسك بتاعها هي
للاسف الفصل بتاع رودينا ما فيهوش كاميرات
والمدرسه ما فيهاش كاميرات فهو هي بتحكي
مع اختها اصيبت بهبوط حد في الدوره
الدمويه ووقعت في الغرفه وباباها نقلها
المستشفى رودينا اتحطت على جهاز تنفس
صناعي القلب رجع اشتغل تاني ولكن للاسف
القلب بتعطل فجاه وفرقت الحقيقه يعني
بالامس فعلا مساء امس النيابه العامه صرحت
بدفن رودينا وطلب التحريات من النيابه من
الاجهزه الشرطه في نفس المسار وزاره
التربيه والتعليم بتحقق بتحقق في الموضوع
ونزلت المدرسه وسالت الطالبات اليوم من
يتحمل مسؤوليه روح رودينا المساله ليست
بالجديده اكثر من مره تعرضت للتنمر قالت
لاهلها اهلها ابلغوا المدرسه وفق
المعلومات ووفق ما اشرت على من تقع
المسؤوليه بدرجه الاولى اليوم
للاسف اداره المدرسه حتى مساء امس اداره
المدرسه وانا بتكلم يعني من مصادر مطلعه
على ثقه وثقه
بالتحيات اداره المدرسه بتم في نفي تام ان
رودينا قبل كده تقدمت بشكوى ضد الطالبات
وبتنفي ان والد رودينا تقدم بشكوى رسميه
وحتى الاخصائيه الاجتماعيه بتاعتها بتنفي
نفي تام حتى الطالبات اللي معاها في
الكلاس بينفو ان هي ان هم ضايقوها او حاجه
وعشان كده بقول لحضرتك للاسف الشديد مفيش
اي كاميرات جوه الفصل توضح هل هي واقعه
موثقه بالنسبه لهم ولا لا الوزاره انا
بقول لحضرتك على مصادر مسؤوله جدا الوزاره
ايديها مخلوله جدا في التحقيقات وهي مضطره
تسيب التحيات للنيابه العامه وتحريات
الشرطه في الموضوع الوزاره ما اعتقدش انها
ممكن تاخد قرار ان هي مش مش قادره توصل
لمعلومه مؤكده موثقه او شكوى مكتوب بخط
ايد رودينا او والد رودينا والد رودينا
راحت حياه في الشغل القانونيه في وزاره
التربيه والتعليم وهذا القصه اللي بحكيها
لحضرتك دي لكنها مش معلنه وقال ان بنته
فعلا تقدمت بشكوى لاداره المدرسه والاخصيه
الاجتماعيه لم تتدخل لكن بعد استدعاء
اداره المدرسه والاخص الاجتماعيه رفضوا رد
تامن ان رودينا تقديمه قبل كده بشكوى
المدرسه
احمد مع من يجري التحقيق مع اداره المدرسه
والطالبات
طبعا اداره والد رودينا بتكلم عن تالت
طالبات بالاسماء هي رودينا قالت اسمائهم
لاختها قبل ما تقع ماتشين عليها وطبعا
والد رودينا قال اسمائهم في تحقيقات
الوزاره التربيه والتعليم وهيقول اسبابهم
في النيابه العامه والنيابه العامه مضطره
تستدعي اداره المدرسه والاخصيه الاجتماعيه
المنوط بها التحقيق في الواقعه بين
الطالبات بعد ما تقدمت بشكوى والطالبات
انا عايز اقول لحضرتك ان في طالب مصري
تعرض يعني عرض نفسه للانتحار في شهر مايو
الماضي بسبب التنمر ودي مش اول موقع تحصل
في مصر كان في طالب ثاني من محافظه
الغربيه في دلتا مصر تناول حبه الغله
السامه السنه اللي فاتت وعشان تنمروا عليه
لانه نظره ضعيف فروح البيت قضى على نفسه
يعني دي وقع وقع مكرره جدا في المدارس
المصريه للاسف الشديد نرجع لمساله
المسؤوليه على من لانه لما بنحكي احنا على
هذه الواقعه حصلت في مدرسه وفي الثانوي
كانه عم نحكي عن لسا اطفال يعني كيف بده
يتم التعامل في قضايا محكمه وتحقيقات مع
اطفال كانه متهمين باقتل غير مباشر لشخص
ما
في المقام الاول توقع على الاسره للاسف في
تباعد بين المسافات بين ادارات المدارس
واولياء الامور يعني يعني في مصر لو عرضت
ابني لو لو قلت امر انها عرض ابنك على
اخصائي نفسي او اجتماع في المدرسه كانك
يعني ارتكبت الجريمه في حقه وتعامل مع
الموضوع ان ده وصمه مجتمعيه في مصر
بيرفضوا ابدا ان الطالب يقعد قدام اخصائي
اجتماعي ونفسي في المدرسه او اللي هي
الامور بيعتقدوا ذلك ان ابنهم مصاب بمرض
نفسي فبيرفضه طبعا جدا يعني وفي نفس الوقت
المدارس معظم المدارس ما فيهاش اخصين
اجتماعيين امام نقص المدرسين في المدرسه
الحكوميه فانت بتواجه معضله تانيه الموضله
الثالثه ان المدارس نفسها مش بتطبق لائحه
انضباط المدرسه على اي طالب
متهم بالتنمر رغم عندهم لائحه انضباط تصل
عقوباتها للفصل النهائي لكن للاسف الشديد
المدارس بتخشى المواجهه الامور فمش
بتطبقوا العقوبه فالمتنمر بيفضل موجود
والمتنمر عليه في نفس الوقت بيفضل يعاني
يعني
شكرا جزيلا من القاهره رئيس قسم التعليم
في بوابه الاهرام احمد حافظ شكرا لك
[موسيقى]